- [Instructor] You put
$3,800 in a savings account.
The bank will provide
1.8% interest on the money
in the account every year.
Another way of saying that,
the money in the savings account
will grow by 1.8% per year.
Write an expression that
describes how much money
will be in the account in 15 years.
So let's just think
about this a little bit.
Let's just think about
the starting amount.
So in the start, we're
just gonna put $3,800.
We could view that as year zero.
Actually, let me write it that way.
So the start is the
same thing as year zero
and we're gonna start with $3,800.
Now let's think about year one.
How much money will we
have after one year?
Well, we would have the original
amount that we put, $3,800,
and then we're gonna get the
amount that we get an interest
and they say that the bank
will provide 1.8% interest
on the money in the account
so it'll be plus 1.8% times $3,800
and we could also write this as a decimal.
This is equal to 3,800
plus and I'll just write,
I'll switch the order
of multiplication here,
plus 3,800 times 0.018.
1.8% is the same thing
as 18,000ths or 1.800ths
depending on how you want to pronounce it.
And so here you might say,
"Well, there's an interesting
potential simplification
"mathematically here."
I could factor 3,800 out
of each of these terms.
I have a 3,800 here, I have a 3,800 here
so why don't I factor it out?
Essentially undistributed.
So this is going to be 3,800 times,
when you factor it out here,
you get a one plus,
you get 0.018
and so I could just rewrite
this as 3,800 times 1.018.
So this is an interesting time to pause.
We're not at the full answer yet,
how much will we have in 15 years,
but we have an interesting expression
for how much we have after one year.
Notice that if the
money is growing by 1.8%
or another way it was growing by 0.018,
that's equivalent to multiplying
the amount that we started the year with
by one plus the amount that
it's growing by or 1.018.
And once again, why does
this make intuitive sense?
Because at the end of the year,
you're going to have the
original amount that you put,
that's what that one really represents,
and then plus you're gonna have
the amount that you grew by
so you multiply both the sum here
times the original amount you put
and that's how much you'll
have at the end of year one.
What about year two?
So year two.
Well, we know what we're going
to start with in year two.
We're gonna start with whatever
we finished year one with.
So we're gonna start
with 3,800 times 1.018,
but then it's gonna grow
by 1.8% or grow by 0.018.
And we already said, if you're
gonna grow by that amount,
that's equivalent to
multiplying it by 1.018.
Well, this is the same
thing as 3,800 times 1.018
to the second power.
I think you see where this is going.
Every time we grow by 1.8%,
we're gonna multiply by 1.018.
And if we're thinking about
15 years in the future,
we're gonna do that 15 times.
So one year in the future,
your exponent here is essentially one.
Two years, your exponent is two.
So year 15, I can just
cut to the chase here,
so year 15,
well that's just going to be,
we're going to have the
original amount that we invested
and we are going to grow 1.018 15 times
so we're gonna multiply
by this amount 15 times
to get the final amount.
And one of the fun things,
this is actually called compound growth
where every year you
grow on top of the amount
that you had before.
You'll see if you type
this into a calculator
that even though 1.8% per
year does not seem like a lot,
over 15 years it actually would amount
to a reasonable amount,
but this is the expression.
They're not asking us to calculate it.
They just want us to know
an expression that describes
how much money will be in
the account in 15 years.